okay.
We've come to the end
of sledgehammer week.
Today's Friday.
yeah, i am going to smash.
what about you?
Oh, very funny smashing sharp.
Right? Final item of the week is a cheap
from an old crappy CRT screen television.
Now we've already done a hammer
through the front of the screen.
So what should we do with this one?
Can a sledgehammer through the top
of the screen.
Yeah see what happens.
We will know how fast glass crash.
I predict it'll be gone
in one frame the whole screen shattered.
Yeah one frame.
It'll take my prediction one and a half.
We have a one shot under this one.
go ahead and the faith.
I actually got hit in the face.
I'm glad I was wearing googles.
I enjoyed that it was good.
actually really pop I'm
not hitting the side
of the head with a bit of flying shrapnel.
All right, Let's see how many
frames this glass cracked in.
I reckon it was good and
my prediction is correct.
So that's the impact .one and
a half dig one and a half.
it's two, three frames of crappy frames.
I think I was close with one and a half,
so yeah, you're right.
And they went from this to that.
That's a faster guys.
What's that video game show where you have
to guess the price or something,
price is right. Price is
right and then you say,
I don't know 2000 pounds and
someone goes two thousand
and one pounds .
yeah Cause
if you're over,
you get nothing. Yeah. But
if you're under a hundred,
you can actually win.
It's just like be that guy, you were like,
it's going to crack in
one frame. I was like,
one and a half frames
even though you can't even
venture for a full frame.
What would be the repair cost on that?
Look at all that in there.
Did i ask someone to repair that?
I take it's probably a lot of glue.
I imagined, just a lot of sort of TV glue.
Is there such a thing as TV
glue to spot on the shelf?
Yeah, that's the little,
I imagine that some sort
of electron fire in device.
Careful!
Hello It's like a sort
of these gramophones.
Thanks for joining us
on our amazing sledgehammer
adventure this week.
Check back next week for
our regular content again,
but I hope you enjoyed
it. See you next time.
[inaudible].